The father should be maintaining the standard of living for that woman
and those children.
And that standard of living includes Kim's whole fucking lifestyle.
Barry should be upholding his fucking vows to that woman
until the divorce is over and until everything's done.
And he should have the same fucking respect for her now in the end
that he had for her in the beginning.
But he's not. So she's left on a fucking boat.
And holding her to the standard of, bitch,
you should be providing for your kids
or you shouldn't have custody for them
is just taking the most misogynistic approach to another woman
who gave everything she had to a man and to these children.
And everybody is leaving that bitch stranded.
Her sons have moved on living with women,
her daughters have moved on,
and she's the one left
having to figure out what's going on in her life.
So, again,
if we're talking about the tribe wife life,
don't fucking do it. It's really fucking risky.
You could give 10, 15,
24 years of your life and end up on your own,
struggling to figure things out.
And then they're gonna try to take your kids and say,
what kind of life can she provide for those kids?
What? Those kids are so much better with the father.
Oh, my god,
look at how she's struggling.
She shouldn't be struggling.
She shouldn't be in that fucking houseboat.
That should not be her situation.
Based on everything that they agreed upon
going into that traditional marriage.
So this is just such a warning to women.
Watch. Welcome to Plathville.
Watch women like myself.
The man that you married is not the fucking man that you're divorcing.
So watch the fuck out.